after numerous leaks Activision has
finally announced Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles mutants in Manhattan the game is
being developed by Platinum Games the
studio behind the band at a series
wonderful 101 and transformers
devastation the first trailer released
today and it's packed with classic
characters and cony one liners that are
sure to make any TMNT fan crack a smile
time to smash some shells the opening
scenes of the trailer are narrated by
the turtles arch enemy shredder as he
shares his diabolical plans to take over
Manhattan some other notable characters
in the trailer other than the turtles
and shredder are april O'Neil Armageddon
Rocksteady and Bebop it looks like this
will tell the story of the foot clams
first assault on New York City and the
origins of the ongoing clash between the
turtles and the foot Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles mutants in Manhattan will
be available summer 2016 on the
playstation 4 playstation 3 xbox one
xbox 360 and pc now if you'll excuse me
I think the pizza guy is knocking at my
door